selfish training partner  currently  he's a pfl guy he's fighting for the  million the guy is [ __ ] slick great  stand up  great take down the fence slick  [ __ ] side beside your funk  killer the worst injury uh broke my  patella I still have a torn quadrice set  missed by my kneecap and that motion  license hit a truck don't [ __ ] hit  trucks you guys it doesn't work out well  trucks are bad worst fan interaction  you know man here's the thing about my  fans  they know that I will hit them in the  [ __ ] face in the street when I see  them so generally they're pretty [ __ ]  they're pretty solid [ __ ] people so I  don't really have badner fan reactions  but to the fans out there if you meet me  in the streets you start running your  [ __ ] mouth I will [ __ ] hit you so  know that  [Music]